I was did a friend but he's not saying
where I got sunburn and his mom rents a
house in Malibu everywhere every summer
for the month of July I was like you
know I'd like to rent something down
there i-i've no I can't of course can't
afford it but I just like to enter into
conversations like that so potentially
calls my bluff she puts me on the phone
with her realtor like a real estate
agent so I'm like okay so what's great
about these la real estate agents is to
like right out of a Robert Altman movie
like they're just exactly what you'd
imagine them to be like yours dialogue
written for them and handed to them
first of all they're always super
familiar with you they're like they're
like a a waiter at Friday's it's a
little weird who's like who gets down on
his knees when you're a little kid
you're there where your dad he's a hey
champ
hey buddy I bet you're pretty hungry I
bet you want some [ __ ] chica fingers
don't it's like you know so III get on a
fall this well of course her name's
Tracey every Realtors name is Tracey
okay Tracey's either the name of a porn
star or a realtor okay and the real
estate is it porn is much more reputable
so I get on the phone with this woman
and she's like hey Tim how are you and
I'm like good and she's like let me tell
you something right now this market in
Malibu it's a real knife fight it's a
real knife fight down here Malibu I
don't care what the government's saying
people are snatching up properties left
and right so I'm just letting you know
what it is and I'm like okay Ike I don't
want to get into a knife fight
in Malibu I can't I will get into maybe
a shoving match in Silver Lake you know
maybe a fender bender in Studio City but
I don't think a knife fight in Malibu is
appropriate and she's like so is your
budget under 40 a month it she means
forty thousand I'm like yeah yeah around
there I mean I'm like cuz if I'm gonna
spend more than I'll just get a house
right she's like right cuz I'll send you
some options because this could be your
summer of love it's a whole different
world out here Tim it's a whole
different worlds that cracked out of her
face she coked out her husband's [ __ ]
her assistant she's like Tim it's a real
knife fight here in Malibu
I haven't felt since I found out my
husband [ __ ] my sister last Christmas
it's a real knife fight here in Malibu
the only thing I ate last week was
adderall and grapefruit juice it's a
real knife fight
Tom armed or
not it's a knife fight here in Malibu my
son thinks he's a woman it's a knife
fight take the blades out and get cut
someone's couldn't caught my name is
Tracy and I'm a real estate agent and
you can't take that away from me
you could take everything my fat sister
and her husband in Ohio those three
disgusting kids she's beat cancer three
[ __ ] times
they're so happy and their above-ground
pool with their poverty but she doesn't
understand I get in that white Jaguar
license plate says sold and I Drive down
the PCH and I say it's a nice side
it's a goddamn nice side are you ready
but not really I'm not really I don't
Tracy Tracy you seem a bit intense I
feel like I'm I'm not really ready for
this what do we soared fine I don't I'm
not ready for him it's that intensity
that she hangs on to her husband blew
her brains out years ago she found his
brain matter all over the kitchen table
she didn't even move it she just sat
there took a little sip of cold brew and
stared right out in the beautiful ocean
she's got a stunning estate just
stunning you it's a knife fight life's a
knife fight that's all your high school
yearbook quote life said life's a knife
fight so I don't think I'll be renting
anything in Malibu so I'm just not
prepared for that level of aggression
what options does she give you anything
I mean I have to email her and I
probably have to tell her I've then I
tell her I have no credit right I'm at
case or anyone in Mal but who wants to
rent me something with no credit I have
money but no credit how do they feel
about hey how do you feel about this let
me talk let's talk about our knife
before we get into the knife fight
because our nice kind of doll I found it
on a train and it's got it has some
dried blood on it so it has worked
before but I just don't know if we can
get you know they probably have a real
nice sharp shiny knife you know from one
of those Japanese block the wood you
know one of those knife collections that
people buy is almost like a samurai
sword and I'm coming in with like a dull
butter
I used to kill a mother the goddamn
knife fight I just love the way they
talk man I love I love real estate
agents I there's nobody I like more then
if there is deep as a puddle there is
deep as a puddle this [ __ ] I mean there
is nothing underneath there it doesn't
go deeper than that sir
it's market hey Tim this markets a real
knife fight so I'll tell you this right
now I don't care what the government's
saying people are snatching up these
properties left and right it's a real
knife fight down here Melba you know how
many times a day she says that hey Karen
how are you Tracy just getting back yep
it's heating up down here mark it's a
real knife fight you know how it is they
make stupid jokes it have to be like you
can't offend anyone so the jokes have to
be like dad jokes you know have to be
like well you know what happens you get
a little tequila I could be a little
wild ha ha I wish I felt you know that's
what there aren't drugs to I mean
they're on there have to be pumping
themselves out because you know here's
the other thing they're not wrong it's
not not a knife fight like it's a lot of
rich people that are just throwing
houses at each other down there and
everybody wants to be in the best place
for the summer well I mean it's just
funny when you hear one of them talk
because they're it's exactly what I
would have imagined heard it it's like
perfect
perfect have you ever met someone and
they were human being and it's so
disappointing and you're like no no
don't tell me
don't tell me your son has MS tell me
it's a knife fight no I want to hear
about the knife fight
I want to hear but the billionaire's
throwing houses at each other on the
beach oh there's only a certain amount
of plots that everyone wants to build no
oh no you have a lump on your breast no
what about the knife thigh can we go
back to the good old knife fight the
fake knife fight that everyone fights
with wire transfers and lawyers